[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY: Hi, I'm Timothy, and
I'm here at Google Cloud Next
London 2018.
And I'm standing with
Deepti, who just gave
a session on a Cloud Spanner.
Now, what's one
feature you talked
about today for the first time
you're really excited about?
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: So
today at London Next,
we launched DML, which is Data
Manipulation Language, which
is basically SQL Insert,
Update, and Deletes,
and I demoed that at my
session, which is very exciting.
And this feature basically
makes it look and smell and feel
a lot more like traditional
relational databases,
so they're very excited
to have the feature.
TIMOTHY: I imagine
that really reduces
the complexity of the Getting
Started experience with Cloud
Spanner.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
That's exactly it.
Spanner is basically a
no compromise database,
and our customers
love it for that
because you get horizontal
scalability, as well
as relational
semantics, transactions,
and strong consistency across
the globe that nobody else has.
However, this was
the one key feature
that was missing
for our customers
because they wanted to use
existing ORMs, existing
tooling, et cetera,
with Cloud Spanner,
which becomes a lot
easier to do now with DML,
with SQL Insert,
Update, Deletes,
and you can use JDBC drivers.
We're launching the database
driver with this capability
today as well, so
it just much easier
for you to use ORMs,
existing tooling,
and to migrate existing apps
or create new apps with this.
TIMOTHY: Thank you, Deepti.
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Thank you, Tim.
I'm sitting here
with Robert Saxbey,
who gave a session yesterday
on-- was it blobs to tables?
Is that right?
ROBERT SAXBY: Blobs to table--
you got it absolutely
right, yeah.
TIMOTHY: Robert, what
was that session about?
ROBERT SAXBY: So that session
was about the different storage
types that we have
at Google Cloud
and how to choose which
one for your use case.
TIMOTHY: If you were to
choose one as your favorite,
what would it be?
ROBERT SAXBY: Oh, I have
at least three favorites.
TIMOTHY: Give me two.
ROBERT SAXBY: Give you two?
OK, I'll give you two.
One is Bigtable.
I love our ability to be
able to actually random read
a single row of data,
a single digit latency,
and scale that up
to infinite size.
We have customers
really reading 10s
of millions of rows
per second, and they
can scale that up
on demand to be
able to address their use case.
The second one has
to be BigQuery.
I'm a data analytics
guy, I mean,
so I'm heavily involved--
heavily invested.
So BigQuery-- first of all,
it's a common misconception,
say, BigQuery, they think,
oh, it's just this one thing?
Yeah, it is one thing.
It's our data warehouse,
but our data warehouse
consists of two parts.
It consists of the storage,
which is capacitor,
and it consists of the
serving tree, the part that
actually runs your SQL query.
Now, from that serving
tree, that seat where
you run your SQL,
you can actually
query our native
storage capacitor
or you can query storage which
is federated to Google Cloud
Storage.
But when it's that
native storage,
we get absolutely
phenomenal performance.
Think about, you have a
petabyte of data in a table.
How long does it
take to query that?
TIMOTHY: Forever.
ROBERT SAXBY:
Forever, absolutely.
So what we do, we partition
it, and we cluster it.
So there was another
talk yesterday,
a talk on BigQuery
performance [INAUDIBLE]..
Then he showed how we can
actually query that data
and get it within a
few seconds by applying
the right partitions and
clusters to your data.
TIMOTHY: That's amazing.
And it actually goes a
lot quicker than forever.
ROBERT SAXBY: Yeah, that's
a lot quicker than forever.
TIMOTHY: I'm standing
next to Henry Bell, who
gave a session on Kubernetes.
Henry, what was the one part
of the session that gets you
most excited about Kubernetes?
HENRY BELL: Right, sure.
So we're doing
quite a lot of work
to integrate the native
Kubernetes world with JCP,
services so thinking
about things
like Cloud Armor
for DDoS protection,
the Identityware proxy
for strong authentication,
and the integrations with
our global load balancer.
So this is a globally
distributed system
that allows us to provide a
single any cost IP address,
and this means that we can
route users to resources
that are near to them.
So for example, you
might have an application
running in two
Kubernetes clusters
in two different regions, which
means that users are routed
to the cluster that's nearest
to them, which means that we can
improve on latency and offer
the best user experience we
possibly can, as well
as being able to provide
nice things really
strong, solid [INAUDIBLE]
redundancy, for example.
TIMOTHY: That's awesome.
Thank you so much, Henry.
HENRY BELL: Thank you.
TIMOTHY: I'm sitting with Oliver
Madden, who gave a session
today about the Chrome browser.
Oliver, could you tell us
what's your favorite feature
of the Chrome browser that,
say, you use in Enterprise,
but average users
might not know about?
OLIVER MADDEN: I'd probably
have to go with legacy browser
support.
TIMOTHY: Tell me about that.
What is it?
OLIVER MADDEN: Basically,
it's an extension
that allows admins to populate
URLs that specifically
need legacy technology, so
Silverlight, ActiveX, et
cetera.
So you can help
your users when they
need that particular
technology, Chrome
will flip into your
designated browser,
probably IE in this case,
just for the duration of that.
And then when they
need or when they
can use a more modern browser,
and they key in the URL,
I don't know, Gmail.com, it will
flip back into Chrome for them.
TIMOTHY: That's amazing.
OLIVER MADDEN: Seamless.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Thanks so much, Oliver.
OLIVER MADDEN: Thank you.
TIMOTHY: Now, Lee's doing a
demo in the Demo Derby later.
Lee, could you give us a quick
synopsis of what the demo is?
LEE BOONSTRA: Sure.
So I'm building this
customer care application
where I'm using Dialogflow
and other Google Cloud
components to create a
real chatbot experience.
TIMOTHY: That's awesome,
and what I really
like about the
demo is that you're
using a bunch of
different JCP components
so that you can create
a complete solution
for this customer care.
LEE BOONSTRA: Oh,
yeah, I'm using a lot.
So actually, I'm using
Kubernetes first of all,
so I create a
front end container
and then back end container.
The back end container
that talks to Dialogflow
through the SDK.
Then every time
when customers, they
type something in the chatbot,
we pass it also to Pub/Sub,
and from Pub/Sub, there
is a cloud function
that captures the message.
It goes into the LP API to
remove sensitive information.
Then we move it to a third LP
API to detect the sentiment,
so people can really figure
out what people are thinking
and if they're happy or not.
And then we pass it into the
data warehouse like BigQuery
so we can push it
into a dashboard,
and then you can really
see some awesome things
and start to optimize
your chatbot.
TIMOTHY: What a cool flow.
LEE BOONSTRA: Yeah.
TIMOTHY: What's your what's your
favorite technology in there?
LEE BOONSTRA:
Definitely Dialogflow.
TIMOTHY: Why is that?
LEE BOONSTRA: Because it's
so easy to create a chatbot.
You don't need to be
technical to set up a chatbot,
but same time, you can go
very deep and use the SDK
and do all crazy stuff.
TIMOTHY: Awesome.
Well, if you want to
find out some more,
click the links in
the description below.
Thanks, Lee.
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank you.